PATIENT.
I'D LIKE TO CALL OUR.
FINAL MEETING OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE TO ORDER AND
TO.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IT WOULDN'T BE IT
WOULDN'T SEEM RIGHT AT THE END
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS OF THEIR
ONE A LITTLE BIT A CHAOS. OF
SEWER JUST GET OURSELVES FOR
ORGANIZED AT THE LAST MINUTE
HERE WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN BY.
TAKING ROLE IN ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM.
LOW. HERE FONG FEAR KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
NOAH PROCEED TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WE HAVE A. BUNCH OF
VOTES TO TAKE UNDER VOTE ONLY.
AND AS A OUR PRACTICES BEEN A
WEEK THAT I HAVE NOT TAKEN
PUBLIC COMMENTS I SHOULD MENTION
THIS YESTERDAY BECAUSE THE
LITTLE BIT OF CONFUSION BUT WE.
WE ON HAVE NOT TAKEN PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR AND SO OF BEING
CONSISTENT WITH THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT. THIS MORNING
EITHER.
.
SO WE'RE GOING TO.
I BEGAN.
OKAY WE HAVE.
.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON ITEMS
THREE FOUR SIX SEVEN TEN
THIRTEEN THROUGH SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY
ONE.
MOVED AND SECONDED LET'S VOTE.
BLOOM.
I FONG.
KALRA. MULLIN
PATTERSON.
NOW IS YOUR MOTION ON ITEM
ELEVEN JUST ITEM ELEVEN.
SO BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
AND TO A MOTION ON ITEMS ONE TWO
FIVE EIGHT NINE TWELVE AND
SEVENTEEN.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
THERE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
TWENTY.
AND.
I'M GOING TO ASK FOR A MOTION BY
DEPARTMENT ON ITEM TWENTY SO
WITHIN ITEM TWENTY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF FOR A.
SUBHEADINGS.
BUT WILL CALL THEM BY.
THE DEPARTMENT SO IS OUR MOTION
TO APPROVE ALL ITEMS UNDER ITEM
TWENTY.
THAT ARE UNDER THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
BLOOM BY FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
THANK YOU. AND THE AND AGAIN
UNDER ITEM TWENTY.
ALL I NAMES THAT ARE LISTED
UNDER OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL.
THEIR MOTION TO APPROVE.
HELLO. I FONG. KALRA. MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
UNDER ITEM TWENTY DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION ALL ITEMS.
BLOOM.
I FONG.
KALRA. MULLIN. PATTERSON.
ALRIGHT I'M I'M GONNA GROUP A A
NUMBER OF FAMILIES SAVE US ALL A
LITTLE BIT OF PAIN HERE AND
GROUP AND TEMPER UPFA
DEPARTMENTS TOGETHER SO IS OUR
MOTION.
.
TO APPROVE ALL ITEMS UNDER THE
FOLLOWING DEPARTMENTS.
UNDERWRITING TWENTY.
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
CALIFORNIA BERMAN A PROTECTION
AGENCY CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AIR RESOURCES BOARD WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. AND
CALTRANS.
BLOOM. BY FONG
KALRA. MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
L. AGAIN UNDER ITEM TWENTY. A
ALL ITEMS LISTED UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION IS OUR MOTION.
HELLO I FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
UNDER ITEM TWENTY.
ALL ITEMS
LISTED UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON
AND FINALLY UNDER ITEM TWENTY
ALL ITEMS LISTED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA. MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND WILL MOVE
TO ITEMS TO BE HEARD. ARE.
FIRST ITEM IS.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE UNDER.
LISTED UNDER VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN PROPOSAL.
I UNDERSTAND ALEJO'S GOING TO BE
PRESENTING GOTTA.
MORNING.
PLEASE WELCOME GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ISSUE ONE ON YOUR ITEMS TO BE
HEARD IS THE.
ASSEMBLY PROPOSED CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED EXPENDITURE PLAN WAS.
HEARD EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THE AGENDA ON PAGE TWENTY EIGHT
AND TWENTY NINE LAYS OUT THE
PROPOSED ASSEMBLY PLAN.
THAT TABLE SPECIFICALLY.
IDENTIFIES SOME OF THE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED PLAN SOME OF THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS.
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
.
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
RESOURCES AN ADAPTATION
ACTIVITIES.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR.
FUNDING FOR PORTS ACTIVITIES IN
REDUCING THE MISSION FROM PORTS
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
SO THE PROPOSED.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE THE.
PLAN THAT'S LAID OUT IN YOUR
AGENDA.
ADOPT PLACE VOTER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
FUNDING PROPOSED FOR THE PORTS.
TO BE USED TO PURCHASE FULLY
AUTOMATED CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT.
THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES YOUR
REPORT.
ALRIGHT PARTNER THE FINANCE.
A GOOD MORNING METAL ME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE
JUST.
.
RECEIVE THIS.
RECOMMENDATION YESTERDAY SO
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING.
I GUESS WE WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED THAT MOST
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ACTION.
APPROVES THE MAJORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS AND CONFERENCE
WE MUST NOT OFFEND OUR JOB WELL.
YOU'RE VERY PLEASED.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR SORRY BUT
YOU'RE ALL LAUGHING EFFECT THAT
STOOD SCOWLING AT ME. ONE I ONE
THING I JUST FORGOT TO MENTION
IF IT THAT'S OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR.
JUST ON NET THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL.
PROPOSES TO SPEND ABOUT TWO AND
A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED SPENDING PLAN.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO.
IF THERE'S NO. QUESTIONS FROM
THE DIET SODA ON THE A PROPOSAL
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
THAT WITH NOW WE'LL SEE IF THEY
WERE REALLY LAUGHING. WITH.
I'M GLAD YOU'RE MOVING THAT
MICROPHONE THAT THAT BOTTLENECK
AT THAT CORNER HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM.
RIGHT GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
HIMSELF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION ON. A ONE NOTE THAT
WE'VE GOT A BUDGET ASKING FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR.
IT'S YOUR MISSION BUSES AND
TRUCKS
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY
OFFERS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE APPRECIATE
THAT. ARE PREFERRED VEHICLE FOR
THAT WOULD BE THE AGE THAT
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES POINT OF
SALE VOUCHERS. THAT ALLOWS FOLKS
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH PROJECTS
WHEN THEY'RE READY TO GO OUT FOR
IT WITH THOSE PROJECTS I DO WANT
TO EMPHASIZE ONE OF THINGS THAT
WE REALLY REALLY DO NEED. IS AN
EMPHASIS ON INFRASTRUCTURE EACH
SHIP CURRENTLY ALLOWS FOR SOME
MONEY TO BE USED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL FOR ACTUALLY BRINGS OUR
MISSION. A BUS PROJECTS ONLINE
ON SO WITH THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CORRIE BOSS.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORDS JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR. THE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO ENERGY
COURSE WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT AND IT WILL YIELD GREAT
WORK WITH THE CCC IN THE LOCAL
COURTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
DANIEL LYNCH ON BEHALF OF THE
OCEAN CONSERVANCY I AM VERY
HAPPY TO SEE THE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENT FOR.
COASTAL ADAPTATION IN THIS
PROPOSAL I WOULD WITHOUT PASSING
THE DETAILS ON THIS EXACT ITEM
HOPE THAT IT DOES INVEST IN THE
FOR STATE LEADERS AN OCEAN AND
COASTAL PROTECTION. INCLUDING
THAT AS HE SEE THE CCC OF THE
ASSET BC DC AND THEN THE OPC
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE APPRECIATE THE INCREASE IN
RESTORATION FUNDING BACK AT THE
LEVEL THAT IT PREVIOUSLY WAS IN
PAST YEARS. BUT REALISTICALLY
THE DEMAND FOR THESE FUNDS IS
FAR GREATER THAN THE AMOUNT
PROPOSED TO BE ALLOCATED THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NO WELL CREAMER'S THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION UNFORTUNATELY WERE
OPPOSED THE REDUCTION IN.
MONEY GOING TOWARDS DIESEL
TRUCKS AND AN AGRICULTURAL
EQUIPMENT. SO THERE'S A
SEVENTEEN PROPOSED SEVENTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR CUT. I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL CONTROL DISTRICT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET WAS ALLOCATED A
HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. TOWARDS REPLACE SEEN
I'M TRACTORS AGRICULTURAL TRUCKS
AND OTHER EQUIPMENT. THEY
TESTIFIED FOR THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WHEN IT OUGHT ADOPTED THE
FARMER PROGRAM GUIDELINES THAT
THEY ALREADY HAD RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS. ABOVE THAT HUNDRED
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS SO WE FEEL
THAT AS MUCH MONEY AS POSSIBLE
IS NEEDED. AND TO HELP US
INVEST IN NEWARK CLEANER BURNING
EQUIPMENT OUT IN ON OUR FARMS
AND RANCHES.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THEY'VE REPLACED OVER FIVE
THOUSAND TRACTORS WHICH IS
REDUCED THIRTY THOUSAND TONS OF
NOTS THEY'VE ALSO REPLACED.
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND OF.
AT THE DIESEL PUMPS FOR
IRRIGATION EQUIPMENT AND WE
THINK THAT.
COMMITTEE IN THESE DOLLARS FOR
INCENTIVES WILL DO A LOT OF WORK
TO HELP REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS WHICH WILL HELP. ON
THE COMMUNITIES IN THESE AREAS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AT YOUR BLOOM AYE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ARION KENNYWOOD CLEAN ENERGY
I'M HAPPY HALF OF MY ABOUT FEELS
COLLEAGUES.
IN THE A PROPANE BAO METHANE.
AYE ETHANOL BIODIESEL INDUSTRIES
WE ARE.
RESPECT WE OPPOSED TO THE ON
LINE ITEM TO TAKE OUT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOW
CARBON FUEL PRODUCTION. AYE.
WHILE FEELS OR WHAT'S RIGHT AND
WHAT'S GOOD ON.
ABOUT THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA.
AYE THESE FUELS ARE WORKING
THEIR PARTY LCF*
AND EIGHTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THE
OFFICE IF THAT'S ACTUALLY AND WE
DO URGE THE COMMITTEE TO RESTORE
THAT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
I THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WAS
TO.
BIG BASS WE BACK FILL IT WITH
G. GIRAFFE.
THROUGH THE A OUR FTP PROGRAM.
THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT BASICALLY
ELIMINATE THAT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WE DO ASK THAT
IT BE RESTORED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRUCE WILLIS AND MORE WHICH I
ORDER AND WE ON BEHALF OF THE
SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AT THE WESTERN COSTS ARE
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY. AND
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND WE WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED
ALLOCATION TO COVER CYCLE TO
ASSIST WITH WASTE DIVERSION
EFFORTS. AND WE STILL SEE A GAP
BETWEEN THE NEED AND THAT
ALLOCATED RESOURCES PARTICULARLY
GIVEN THE FORTHCOMING SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE MANDATES.
AND THAT WE ARE PATIENT AND
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU JULIE MALINOWSKI
ABOUT THE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION AND ONE EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE INVESTMENTS MADE
IN THIS PROPOSAL ON ON LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION ISSUES.
AND I JUST NEED CLARIFICATION
THAT THESE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS AND PILOT PROJECTS ARE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS NOT PART OF
THE ONE FIFTY.
SO I'M ASSUMING SO I WOULD SAY.
THAT THAT.
THAT ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IS IS
ALSO.
UP WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ON BEHALF OF THE.
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE ONE A SUPPORT THE THEM
THE MONEY FOR HEALTHY FORESTS A
GRANT PROGRAMS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE.
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS AND FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR A LOCAL
SUPPORT.
THAT GOES TO A WE ASK THAT WE
HOPE THAT AS THIS GOES FORWARD
RECONSIDER THAT A FLOOR TO WHAT
IS NEEDED BY THE LOCALS. TO UP
PREPARE IN PRE POSITION AND
UPGRADE OUR MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
THINK.
GOOD MORNING BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR WANT
TO EXTEND OUR THANKS IN SUPPORT
FOR THE INCREASES FOR THE HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS THOSE.
DEMONSTRATION PILOT PROJECTS ARE
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED RELATED TO
THAT WE ALSO SUPPORT THE FUNDING
FOR PORTS.
OR CLEANING UP THEIR OPERATIONS
AND WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THAT
MONEY GO TO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD SO THAT THEY CAN FIND THE
MOST EFFECTIVE PROJECTS.
WE ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE
INCREASES IN THE LOW INCOME
ENERGY PROGRAMS AND URBAN
CLEANING AND URBAN FORESTRY. ARE
AND WE STILL WOULD LIKE TO SEE
AN INCREASE IN THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM TO
ACCOMMODATE THE NEED FROM MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ASKING FOR
THAT FUNDING AND.
SPEND IT IN AN INTEGRATED
COORDINATED MANNER THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MATTHEW WELL OF WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE.
PRODUCTION OF SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON THAT DIESEL
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM
IT SIMPLY ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M AARON EVANS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES WE
APPRECIATE MUCH OF WHAT'S IN
THIS ALLOCATION PLAN.
.
SPECIFICALLY URBAN FORESTRY
URBAN GREENING OF THE BEACON
PROGRAMS. BUT WE ALSO APPRECIATE
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
ENHANCEMENT OF THE FOLLOWING
PROGRAMS.
FIRST LOCAL FIRE RESPONSE.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
I'M SECONDLY WASTE DIVERSION
WE'D APPRECIATE THE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S IN THE
PLAN. A BULLET CERTAINLY URGE AN
INCREASE THEREFORE AT THE NEED
AND DEMAND IN THAT AREA. I'M AND
FINALLY THE TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND
CAN BE REPLICATED AND MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE STATE.
SO WE'D LIKE TO URGE AN INCREASE
FOR THAT AS WELL THANK YOU.
CORNING CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL MASON
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST AYE WERE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INVESTMENTS IN FORESTS AND. THE
OTHER FIRE AND RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS THERE THEY WERE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MAY REVISE
PLEASE DO YOU CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THOSE. ALSO I THANK YOU
FOR THE AUGMENTATIONS AT THE END
OF THE.
YOUR LIST HERE AND ADAPTATION
WHICH ITEM IS THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION CORPS BOARD PROGRAM
BEING CONTINUED AND WETLANDS AND
WATERSHEDS THOSE ARE OBVIOUSLY.
NOWHERE NEAR THE THEY DON'T
REFLECT THE NEED BUT THEY DO
REFLECT CONTINUING THIS PROGRAM
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION MORE
KNOWING HE JACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA JERRY ZINC CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ART
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA TOMATO GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND VARIOUS OTHER.
AG AND CITIES.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE AND
SUPPORT THE FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
GIVEN TO THE ACT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND. METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAMS IN THIS.
IN THIS PLAN THOSE ARE GOING TO
HAVE GREAT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION.
.
A BENEFITS EXPRESSLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
MANY OF THESE FACILITIES ARE AND
CONTINUE TO HELP PROMOTE JOBS IN
THOSE INDUSTRIES.
WE DO HAVE CONCERN HOWEVER WITH
THE REDUCTION IN FUNDS FOR A THE
AG DIESEL ENGINE REPLACEMENT.
PROGRAM AND AS WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE IT THE FARMER PROGRAM IN
THE CARL MOYER PROGRAM WHEN IT
COMES TO THESE TYPES OF DIESEL
EQUIPMENT ARE ARE ALREADY.
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
IN SO WE COULD REALLY USE THIS
FUNDING TO GET THESE REDUCTIONS
AND HELP FARMERS AS THEY ARE.
UPGRADING THEIR EQUIPMENT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING
THOSE REDUCTIONS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS CHAISSON
BRIAN TO BEHALF OF WESTERN AYE
DURING MEN FOR SOFT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE ALLOCATION
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT OUTLINED
IN THE PROPOSAL HERE. THAT'S A
CRITICAL PROGRAMS GOING TO HELP
TERRY FAMILIES TRANSITION AND TO
HELP US ACHIEVE OUR METHANE
REDUCTION GOALS WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AN INCREASE.
IN THE AG DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM AS INDICATED
BY. OUR FRIENDS AND.
WHO SPOKE EARLIER ON THAT ISSUE
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
METHANE ALLOCATION VERY MUCH
THANK YOU?
GOOD MORNING BETH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
ROUNDING OUT THE SUPPORT OF THE.
NINETY NINE MILLION FOR METHANE
REDUCTION REALLY IMPORTANT HELP
THE STATE OUR THIRTY THREE GOALS
AND ALSO I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY AG FRIENDS ON THE DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM AT
THAT FUNDING. HOPE TO STEAL MORE
THERE THINK IF.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COST VARIX ON BEHALF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND WE
REALLY SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY IS
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE PLAN BUT
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP BY THE ASSEMBLY IN
CHAMPIONING. THAT'S A RESOURCE
ISSUES IN PARTICULAR INCLUDING A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS HEALTHY
FORESTS COASTAL ADAPTATION
NATURAL LANDS ADAPTATION
WETLANDS RESTORATION URBAN
FORSTER BEEN GRINNING HEALTHY
SOILS AND SWEEP. AND ALSO OF
COURSE OTHER HUMAN CENTERED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
AARON ROBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
GRAIN AND FEED ASSOCIATION THE
SEED ASSOCIATION AND PACIFIC EGG
AND POULTRY ASSOCIATION ECHOING
THE SAME COMMENTS AS MY AG
FRIENDS. WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSED CUT TO THE DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT THANK YOU.
ESTIMATE OF WORSE ON BEHALF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA OF
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE WASTE
DIVERSION PROGRAM UP TO FORTY
MILLION. A GOOD ALLY MYSELF
OTHER COMMENTS THAT THAT IS NOT
ADEQUATE FOR US TO IMPLEMENT THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PENDING ACCOUNT RECYCLE. ON AND
ALSO WHEN I I URGE MORE FUNDING
FOR THE TRANSFERRING OF CLIENT
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM. UP COUNTIES
AND CITIES HAVE.
ASK FOR A HUNDRED MILLION AND
THAT.
POT ON SO THAT.
SUSAN COUNTIES CAN USE PROJECTS
THAT HELP WITH GRASS GRASS
SUGGESTIONS WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MORE MONEY
IN THAT POT BUT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE INCREASE IN THE
WASTE DIVERSION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM HOLLY ON THE.
AT LAWRENCE BERKELEY LAB TECH
THAT ALSO ASKED ME TO CONVEY
THEIR SUPPORT MOVE BUT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF. YOUR OUR OR
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
GOV OF OF THE CLIMBING CLEAN
ENERGY. RESEARCH FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY SPECIFICALLY THE
GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE CHANGE
TECHNOLOGY AND SOLUTIONS
INITIATIVE ARE AT THE STRATEGIC
CROSSED CAO.
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WE COME MONSTER TO NON
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THE RESTORATION OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCE PROGRAMS
THE ADAPTATION PROGRAMS THAT
WERE MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE
AT TNC. URBAN FORESTRY URBAN
GREENING.
WETLANDS THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT I AND AS ON FRIEND
FROM PF HE SAID.
THEY DON'T REFLECT THE NEED BUT
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO KEEP
THESE PROGRAMS GOING I REALLY I
THINK YOU FOR THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BODY
HOMES CHEN WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT.
FOR YOUR BUDGET PACKAGE THAT IT
UP PROVIDES CLEAN AIR
INVESTMENTS AND FUNDING FOR THE
TRANSITION TRANSITION TO ZERO
MISSION VEHICLES IN THE LIGHT
AND HEAVY DUTY SECTOR.
WE HAVE SOME SPECIFIC COMMENTS.
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OUR MISSION
VEHICLE INVESTMENT PLAN. AS THAT
GOES TO CONFERENCE WE WOULD ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER.
THE FULL TO WHERE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION AND APPRECIATE. YOUR.
LANGUAGE THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
TO ENSURE THERE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR BOTH LIGHT AND HEAVY DUTIES
ARE MISSION ME TO MOVE BOTH
THOSE. AYE SECTORS FORWARD
QUICKLY.
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR CLEAN
TRUCKS BUSES OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
BUT OF COURSE THERE'S ALWAYS TOO
LITTLE GIVEN ESPECIALLY I
COMMUTE EXPOSURES TO DIESEL SO
IT WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
INCREASE TO THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY.
MILLION AND.
SUPPORT OTHER MEN VESTMENTS
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE INCENTIVES
OFFER LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES AND
ONE TO CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE NEED FOR SOME. INCREASED.
SOME FUNDING FOR ZEV MARKETING
AND OUTREACH THIS IS A NEED
THAT'S NOT ADDRESSED.
WE'D DESPERATELY NEED INCREASED
PUBLIC EDUCATION EFFORTS
PROMOTING THE MANY CHOICES
AVAILABLE FOR SERVICE VEHICLES
HEALTH BENEFITS
AND.
PROVIDING OF ENCOURAGEMENT TO
ALL COMMUNITIES TO OUT UTILIZED
OF OPTIONS AND AND PROVIDE THOSE
INCENTIVES ALL COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR EFFORTS
GENERALLY TO SUPPORT AB SIX ONE
SEVEN THE COMMITTEE ARE
PROTECTION PROGRAM INCLUDING.
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE FUNDING
YOU PREFER YOU PROPOSED OUT OR
YOU APPROVED EARLIER FOR AIR
DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
JOSHUA STARK WITH TRANSFORM AND
BY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
SUSTAINABLE COMMITTEES FOR ALL.
A COALITION OF CONSERVATION
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING ADVOCACY
AND I SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT ADDING
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS HEADING
BACK FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS THAT
TRULY IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY IN THE LIGHT WHIP.
URBAN FORESTRY IN URBAN GREEN
PROGRAMS.
SEPARATELY ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORM ALSO APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING FOR RESEARCH INTO THE
TRANSIT PASSES.
MORNING TERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
CHUCK MILLS THE CALIFORNIA LEAF
ALSO MEMBERS SUSUMU COMMITTEES
FRAUD COALITION AND HOW TO SLIDE
MY COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF RELIEF
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
TRANSFORM. BUT THEN ALSO ON
BEHALF OF TREAT PEOPLE AND
AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA ON THE LINE
MY COMMENTS WITH THAT TNC. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LEADERSHIP AND
RESTRAIN INVESTMENTS NATURAL
RESOURCES WETLANDS URBAN GREEN
URBAN FORESTRY OTHERS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TYRONE BUCKLEY OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE'RE ALSO
MEMBER OF SUSTAINABLE COMMUTES
FRAUD COALITION PROSELYTE
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR.
THE PARTY SUGGESTED BY THE
PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
JEAN EMAIL WITH A CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE TEN AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
WHILE THE ASSEMBLY PLAN OFFERS
SOME FUNDING FOR A
TRANSFORMATIVE ACTS SOLUTIONS A
TO CLIMATE CHANGE HEALTHY SOILS
AND SWEEP. OF THE FUNDING LEVELS
ARE WOEFULLY INADEQUATE FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF FARMERS THAT ARE
COALITION WORKS WITH.
AND WE URGE THE ASSEMBLY TO
RECONSIDER A SUSTAINABLE AG
INVESTMENTS ON IN CLIMATE CHANGE
SOLUTIONS.
AND SPECIFIC TO DAIRY METHANE WE
CONTINUE TO URGE.
A SPECIFIC ALLOCATION FOR THE
ALTAR NOR MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
PROGRAM A FORTY MILLION.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ANDREW AND
WE WOULD SHOW YOUR HAND TO THE
HERO.
ON THE NUMBER OF ITEMS.
FIRST UNFORTUNATELY WITH
RESPECT TO MUST OPPOSE.
THE FOR THE ELEMENT OF THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL.
THAT.
REDUCES THE LOW CARBON.
ELEMENT A FUNDING FROM. THE AB
ONE EIGHTEEN SLASH AB EIGHT
FUNDING PROGRAM. OF THE LOW
CARBON PROGRAM DOWN TO ZERO FROM
TWENTY FIVE. AND THAT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN PROPANE
GAS ASSOCIATION.
WE SEE KIND OF A TREND IN
HAVING AN EMPHASIS ON ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND WE'RE NOT
HERE TO STAND THE WAY OF THAT
BUT. WHO WOULD VERY MUCH
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER?
FUEL DIVERSITY.
AND HAVING KIND OF A BALANCED
PORTFOLIO AND E DO THINK THAT
ESPECIALLY IN THE RENEWABLE OF
VERSIONS OF THESE FUELS THEY
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY GOING
FORWARD. AND THEY'RE WORTHY OF
INVESTMENT GOING FOR THEIR PART
OF THE STATE'S.
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD AND.
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT THE RIGHT CARD
INTENSITY LEVELS.
THIS IS A GOOD STRATEGY AND
WORTHY OF INVESTMENT SO. WE URGE
RECONSIDERATION OF THAT ITEM
GOING FORWARD HOPEFULLY THROUGH
CONFERENCE.
AND THEN ON BEHALF OF THE PORT
OF LOS ANGELES I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL.
WE REWARD REALLY.
WE THINK THAT'S A GREAT REWARD
FOR THE WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
ESPECIALLY DOWN AT THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES. WE'VE INVESTED IN A
MULTI YEAR PLAN THIS IS OUR
THIRD ITERATION OF THE CLEAN AIR
ACTION PLAN THAT'S BEEN FILE
JOINTLY AND UPDATED LIKE I SAID
FOR THE THIRD TIME.
VERY HAVE A VERY BOLD OR ZERO
MISSION GOAL DOWN AT THE PORT OF
LA AND THAT'S FOR HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS AND ALSO FOR CARGO
HANDLING EQUIPMENT GOING
FORWARD.
AND. OUR LONG TERM GOAL TO SEE A
MUCH BIGGER SOURCE OF FUNDING AT
THE STATE LEVEL SO THE STATE CAN
BE A FUNDING PARTNER WITH THIS
AND WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD
DOWN.
PAYMENT ON THAT INVESTMENT.
AND THEN LASTLY ARE FOR LA
METRO.
WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE ELEMENT
OF THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL
REGARDING AGE PHILIP OF WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ELIGIBILITY FOR.
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL.
WE LIKE THE LINE ITEM IN THE.
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL FOR THAT
AND WE SUPPORT THAT. AND THEN
LASTLY FOR EARLY METRO WE
SUPPORT THE PREVIOUS VOTE ONLY
ITEM. OF STUDYING.
TRANSIT PASSES
AND SUBSIDIES FOR THAT.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENCE MAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
FORCED COUNCIL. PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE TRUST AND SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACE THIRTY ONE
ECHO THAT COMMENTS FROM THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT OF THE
NATIONAL WORKING LANCE FUNDING.
REALLY APPRECIATIVE THAT THAT'S
BEING CARRIED FORWARD ESPECIALLY
AS THIS YEAR'S THE FIRST YEAR
WE'VE SEEN A TARGET AND SCOPING
LAND FOR MISSION REDUCTIONS FROM
THE SECTORS. ALSO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS MONEY FOR COASTAL AND
NATURAL AND ADAPTATION AS WE'RE
SEEING THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE CERTAIN A HIT THESE AREAS
OF THE STATE. ARTIST IN FIRST
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND TROUT
UNLIMITED.
IN SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
SPECIFICALLY.
FOR INCLUDING FUNDING FOR AN
ACTUAL WORKING LANCE THANK YOU.
HE BE SEEN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
AND WE'VE SUBMITTED I'M A LETTER
HIGHLIGHTING ARE. OUR WHAT'S
CREIGHTON AND WHAT WHAT WHAT
COULD IMPROVE.
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
THINGS REALLY REALLY WANT TO SEE
A BIGGER INVESTMENT THE CHANCE
PHONE OF CLIMATE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM WE'VE SEEN THAT ALREADY
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES. AND THINK WHAT THE
MORE ROBUST AND AND INVESTMENT
AND COULD HAVE MORE AND.
ALSO ON THE NINETY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT METHANE
MANAGEMENT FEEL THAT THAT COULD
BE BETTER USED ON SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES.
THINGS SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING STEVE ALLOCATE ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
TRANSLATION VARMINTS WILK
EXPRESSIVE HE SUPPORT FOR THE
FUNDING FOR THAT THE TRUCK AND
BUS AND UP ROAD VEHICLE PROGRAM
PARTICULARLY THE ADDED FUNDS FOR
THE AT. A DEMONSTRATION PILOT
PROJECTS WITH THE CLOSER. WILEY
NEEDED TO GET THIS TECHNOLOGY TO
COMMERCIAL VIABILITY.
CHAIRMAN BLOOM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF MY NAME IS MARK ON HIS
ARROGANT I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LOCAL BUT IF YOU
ACCOMPLISH ENOUGH. WORD
ASSOCIATION OF FARM WORKER
PROGRAMS TO SEARCH THE WHOLE
STATE.
WE ARE HERE VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT YOU HAVE PUT SOME MONEY
INTO RESTORING. THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
S. PROGRAMS DO MUCH NOT ONLY TO
LOWER OF CARBON FOOTPRINT OF.
SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND FARM WORKERS
WHO OWN HOMES.
BUT IT ALSO DOES MUCH
TO RAISE THIS THEIR DISPOSABLE
INCOME.
WHICH IS OF MUCH BENEFIT TO
MITIGATE THEIR IMPOVERISHED
CONDITIONS.
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SEE THE
RESTORATION OF A LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM WE THANK
YOU AND I BOTH SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC COM.
SUPPORT OF OF THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMITMENT TO LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION REFLECTED IN THE
SPENDING PLAN WE WOULD LIKE TO
LET OUR COMMENTS WITH. KELLY T.
C. WHICH SPOKE EARLIER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THINK FOR ALL OF THOSE
COMMENTS.
OF THAT MANY OF THREE I ITEM
SAID THAT WERE BROUGHT UP A
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO WERE
DISAPPOINTED BY.
SOME OF THE ALLOCATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE OF THE. SUBJECT OF
CONTINUE CONVERSATION AS WE GO
INTO A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE I
DID WANT TO POINT OUT WITH
RESPECT TO THE. A COOKED OCT
COUPLE OF FOLKS DRIVE SPOKE
ABOUT THE LOW CARBON FUEL
PRODUCTION.
.
ITEM.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING TWENTY
FIVE MLLION IN THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL IS FOR ZERO BUT THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF.
.
MISUNDERSTANDING THERE I THINK.
THE.
THE GOVERNOR ACTUALLY.
HAD BEEN FUNDING OR THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD BEEN FUNDING
THAT PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF THE CAP
AND TRADE BUDGET AND IS ZEROED
OUT IN THAT PART OF THE BUDGET
IS NOW. INSERTED INTO THE CAP
AND TRADE BUDGET.
SO THE FUNDING REMAINS LEVEL
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL LEAVES
TWELVE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING AND.
THE A ARE F. VTP AND FOR YOU
ACRONYM THAT'S OUT THERE HUMP
THAT SO THE ALTERNATIVE
RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM. SO THERE IS
A REDUCTION.
WELL OVERALL BUT IT'S HALF OF
WHAT YOU THINK IT IS.
BOB SAID I JUST WANT TO POINT
THAT OUT.
I GET THAT RIGHT.
COULD JOB BLOOM.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MISTER MILLER.
JUST THINKING WHICH CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR OF ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THESE VARIOUS CAP AND
TRADE ITEMS I JUST WANTED.
NOTE.
MY PARTICULAR SUPPORT FOR
COASTAL ADAPTATION WETLANDS IN
THE URBAN FORESTRY GREENING
CATEGORIES THAT WERE ADMITTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT.
HAVE FOUND A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
IN THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL. IN
JUST ON THE AG DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT WE HAVE RECEIVED
QUITE A BIT OF TESTIMONY NOT
ONLY TODAY BUT IN PREVIOUS.
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS AND AS
YOU INDICATED HIS CHAIR THAT
WILL BE A SUBJECT OF SOME
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION IN
CONGRESS TO HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
THE SENATE.
LINE ITEM IS ON THAT PARTICULAR
ITEM DO WE HAVE A SIDE BY SIDE
OF THAT IT JUST IT'S A
CURIOSITY.
WE DO WE JUST NEED TO FIND IT ON
THEIR PROPOSAL.
SO THEY THEY.
OFFENDED A HUNDRED TWO MILLION.
THEY CONFORMED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
SO THAT WILL BE AND CONFERENCE
AND THAT CERTAINLY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE. WHAT THE
CONFEREES CAN CONTINUE TO TO
DISCUSS?
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND NAPA IS IF THERE A MOTION ON
THIS ISSUE.
ISSUE ONE.
THE ASSEMBLY CAP AND TRADE TO
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
LAMB.
I FONG.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT ISSUE.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD IS ISSUE THEIR ISSUE ONE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSALS.
OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA.
WHICH JUST CHECK THEN AND
CONFIRM THAT ELLIOT FISK AND
MAKE A PRESENTATION ON THIS ITEM
TO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU RELATES TO
THE GOVERNOR'S ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INITIATIVE WHICH JUST AS
REMINDERS BEEN HEARD IN PREVIOUS
HEARINGS BUT INCLUDES.
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR TO ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOUR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS WELL AS TO WHETHER MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR.
REBATES FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
SO THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU.
THAT'S A STAFF BUT THAT THE
STAFF IS RECOMMENDING INCLUDES A
VARIETY OF PIECES SO THAT
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING ACTIONS.
ADOPTING PLATE PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO CONDUCT
AN ANNUAL EVEY MARKET STUDY.
IN THAT MARKET STUDY WOULD
INCLUDE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT.
THINGS INCLUDING MODEL IN.
PROJECTIONS OF SAYS OUT TO AT
LEAST TWENTY THIRTY.
INCLUDING PROJECTED SALES
FIGURES AND IMPACTS OF FEDERAL
POLICY CHANGES AMONGST OTHER
THINGS.
THE REPORT WOULD ALSO INCLUDE
SURVIVOR RESULTS OF CONSUMER
AWARENESS AND ACCEPTANCE OF EP'S
AND AWARENESS OF CHARGING
STATION LOCATIONS.
AND MODEL SEVERAL A REBATE
SCENARIOS GIVEN.
DATA IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE REBATE OR A PROGRAM TO
MAXIMIZE REBATE EFFECTIVENESS.
IT WOULD ALSO DOT PLACE ORDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
CODIFIES THE GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF
FIFTY MILLIONS AS BY TWENTY
THIRTY.
REQUIRES A ARE BE TO USE THE
CDC STUDY TO ESTIMATE THE TOTAL
STATE REBATE INVESTMENT
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS.
REQUIRES A ARE BE TO USE THE
STUDY TO RECOMMEND ANNUAL
CHANGES TO THE CVR P. IN REBATE
STRUCTURE.
.
TO MEET THE FIVE MILLION EVEY
GOAL BY TWENTY THIRTY.
REQUIRES A RB TO DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN A CUSTOMER BUYING GUIDE
THAT INCLUDES INFORMATION.
ABOUT MAKES AND MODELS OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AVAILABLE TO
CONSUMERS
AS WELL AS INFORMATION ON
INCENTIVES.
ALSO AS IT RELATES TO AND I'M.
ON PAGE THIRTY TWO NOW OF YOUR
AGENDA AS RELATES TO THE EEVEE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE OF
THE PROPOSAL.
VIA A RECOMMENDATION BEFORE YOU
WOULD BE TO APPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FUNDING
PROPOSAL FOR IS THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. BUT.
AS MISTER CHAIR MENTION NOT
BACK FILL THE LOW CARBON FUEL
PRODUCTION WITH TWENTY FIVE
MILLION CAP AND TRADE FUNDING
AND INSTEAD FOR THE BUDGET YEAR.
PROVIDE TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION FROM THE A. R. S. B. T.
F..
SO FUNDING FOR
FROM A OUR FTTP WOULD BE.
SIXTY FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
PLUS SOME OF THE OTHER ONE TIME
FUNDS THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING.
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NO LONGER
PURSUING THE EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE NEW
SOLAR HOME PARTNERSHIP FUNDING
THAT WOULD GO TO SEVEN FOR
STRUCTURE AND THAT THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL. WOULD SIMILARLY NOT
INCLUDED.
THAT FUNDING FOR SEVEN FOR
STRUCTURE.
THE PROPOSAL WHAT ADOPTS PLACE
WHERE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES C. C. TO INCLUDE IN
THEIR ANNUAL STUDY. OF GAPS IN
EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE.
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT OF THE
EEVEE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT.
THE FIVE MILLION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE GOAL AS WELL AS THE
STATE'S FORTY PERCENT GHG
REDUCTION GOAL OUT TWENTY
THIRTY.
IT WOULD ADOPT PLACE ORDER
TRAILED A LANGUAGE THAT REMOVES
THE PROHIBITION ON AIR BE FROM
ENACTING REGULATIONS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE BUILDING OF HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS.
A PROHIBITION WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED AND LEGISLATION A
FEW YEARS AGO.
AND FINALLY WOULD REQUIRE CC TO
DEVELOP A STANDARD INFORMATION
LABEL FOR ALL PUBLIC CHARGING
STATIONS TO HELP CONSUMERS.
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS WHEN
THEY.
PURCHASE ELECTRIC
FROM THE STATIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
SIMILAR TO OUR.
.
DISCUSSION ON CAP AND TRADE WE
JUST RECEIVED THIS UP PROPOSAL
AYE YESTERDAY AND SO WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE THE DETAILS BUT WE
ARE PLEASED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION. REFLECTS US SOMEWHERE
POLICY GOALS
OTHER THE ADMINISTRATION HAS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS INCOME.
THANK YOU
DID YOU WANNA ANYTHING.
IS A PUBLIC COMMENT.
I I GOOD MORNING RANKING THE
CLEAN ENERGY A MAP OF OUR ABOUT
FEELS COALITION ABOUT YOUR BLOOM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. YOUR
COMMENTS CLARIFYING THE ABOUT
FEELS PROVISIONS AND WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED COURSE WITH THE
REDUCTION IN MONEY AND WE'LL
KEEP WORKING HOPEFULLY WITH YOU
ON THE COMMITTEE AND AND.
TRY RESTORE THAT BUT MY
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW IS CENTERED
ON THE TRAILER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
AND IT DOES I RIGHT NOW I GOT
THE FUEL AND TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRALITY LANGUAGE IT'S IN
THERE THE PROGRAM IS FOUR ZERO
AND NEAR ZERO I. FEELIN IN
VEHICLES AND WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MAKING THIS MORE OF A ZERO
EMISSION OP PROGRAM.
AND DEATH FOCUSING MORE TO
COMPLY IS A FUNDING MECHANISM
FOR THE EXECUTIVE ORDER FOUR
FIVE MILLION SEVEN BY TWENTY
THIRTY SO WE DO ASK THAT.
CONSIDERATION BE TAKEN THAT
LANGUAGE IS NOT INCLUDED
STRIKING OUT THE A NEW TROUT YOU
TYPE YOU TRY LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JULIE NON ASK ABOUT
THE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION I HAVE
THREE POINTS TO MAKE FIRST AGAIN
SUPPORT OF THE SUPPORT FROM THIS
COMMITTEE FOR LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION IS MUCH
APPRECIATED.
THAT REDUCTION AND THAT IS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS IS
SOMETHING WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
BETTER HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND THIS GOES TO CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ON MAKING SURE THAT
THIS LONG OVERDUE POLICY. OF
PUTTING LARGER INVESTMENTS IN
SEVEN TO STRUCTURE.
IS MADE WHOLE THE GAP IS STILL
QUITE HIGH BETWEEN WHAT IS BEING
MADE.
INVESTMENTS BEING MADE BY THE
BY THE STATE BY THE UTILITIES BY
ELECTRIFY AMERICA IS STILL
PRETTY HIGH SO ANY REDUCTION IS
OF A CONCERN. AT TWO POINTS ON
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND THE AIR BE STUDY THAT WOULD
RECOMMEND ANNUAL CHANGES TO THE
CD R. P. STRUCTURE.
I WOULD PROCEED WITH CAUTION ON
THAT ANNUAL CHANGES WOULD HAVE
BIG IMPACTS ON THE MARKET AND
WHAT CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND FROM
YEAR TO YEAR OF WHAT THEIR
INCENTIVES MAY OR MAY NOT BE. SO
MAYBE ANNUAL CHANGES.
MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT WAY TO GO
SO SOMETHING WE CAN WORK ON IN
THE LANGUAGE AND ON THE LAST
POINT REQUIRING THE CDC TO
DEVELOP A STANDARD INFORMATIONAL
LABEL ON ALL PUBLIC CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WEIGHTS AND
MEASURES IS WORKING ON THIS
ALREADY SO I WOULD HOPE WHATEVER
THE CDC. IS DOING THEY'RE DOING
IT AND NOT DUPLICATIVE OF WHAT
WEIGHTS AND MEASURES WERE
QUEUING IS MAYBE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY I WE
WANTED TO SIGNAL OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S AS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE GOALS. AS WELL AS HIS
CALL TO PROVIDE A MORE STABLE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR REBATES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE ALSO VERY
MUCH IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN REGARDS TO THE
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT. OF THE EPA
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT THE LEVELS OF LEVY
ADOPTION AS CALLED FOR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S SCHOOLS. THINK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OFFER YOUR
COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE DYESS IF
NOT IS THERE A MOTION.
ADOPT ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL.
Q. MISTER MULLIN I'LL SECOND
THAT.
LYNN.
BY PHONE.
KALRA.
MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT
FOR ADD ONS.
AND EACH.
OUR FINAL ITEM.
FOR THE HEARING AND FOR THIS
BUDGET YEAR.
WILL BE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
CALTRANS.
ISSUE ONE TRANSPORTATION RELATED
LEGISLATION.
THERE ARE TWO BULLET POINTS ON
THIS.
AND WE HAVE FOR.
ELLIE O. PRESENTING.
PAUL GOES IF GIVEN THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THERE'S TO LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
FOR TRANSPORTATION RELATED
TRAILER BILL LADEN MUCH BEFORE
YOU THE FIRST PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO USE
THEIR OWN FUNDS TO PAY FOR
ELIGIBLE SP ONE LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS PROJECTS.
AND THEN LATER BE REIMBURSED FOR
THEIR FUTURE SB ONE FUNDING. AND
SO THIS WOULD HAVE ESSENTIALLY
ALLOW THEM ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO ACCELERATE THEIR
PROJECTS UNDER SB ONE.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE DISTRICTS
TO USE THE PROJECT DELIVERY
METHOD.
KNOWN AS CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
OR GENERAL CONTRACTOR OR CMG
SEE.
UNDERSTAND YOU SEE THE
DISTRICTS COULD WORK WITH A
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER DURING THE
DESIGN PHASE OF A PROJECT ON
ISSUES SUCH AS COST AND
SCHEDULE.
ARE CURRENTLY.
OTHER BRIDGES ARE CERTAIN
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES HAVE
THIS AUTHORITY ON CALTRANS ALSO
HAS LIMITED CMG SEE ACCORDING.
THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE HAVE NO CONSIDER THE PROPOSAL
OF DAMON KNOCKED PARTNER
FINANCE.
HA THEM OTHER ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE DYESS IS ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT.
PEOPLE.
GET THAT MIKE ON.
THERE YOU.
HESKEY WELCOMED AFTER THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY AND
TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT.
LETTER URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THAT THAT LANGUAGE ON THE SCENE
TO SEE FOR A BIRD THE GOAL GET
BRIDGE DISTRICT THIS IS A
CONTRACTOR METHOD THAT'S GONNA
BE CRITICAL FOR THEM TO DO THE
NEXT PHASE FOR SUCH A
RETROFITTING. BUT ALSO THE
COORDINATION SKINNER REQUIRED
FOR A CAS DURING THAT
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ALSO CAN BE
THE CONSTRUCTION WORK ON
INSTALLING THE SUICIDE BARRIER
ON THE BRIDGE SO THAT IS ONE
REASON WHY WE REALLY WANT THIS
AUTHORITY.
THANKS.
THANK YOU.
THAT CLOSES THE PUBLIC HEARING
IF.
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FROM THE DICE IS THERE A MOTION
ON.
ISSUE ONE.
SECOND.
BLOOM AYE FONG.
KALRA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN FOR
MR KARAS ADD ON AND TO AS WE
CLOSE OUT OUR FINAL HEARING I
WANT TO.
.
THANK GOD.
MY COLLEAGUES A CAR BUDGET CHAIR
OF COURSE SAID MR TANG BUT UP
PARTICULARLY MESSRS FONG
PATTERSON. KALRA AND MULLIN
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND INTEREST AND
AND DATA.
.
ONGOING ATTENDANCE AT WHAT HAS
BEEN SOME VERY TEDIOUS MEETINGS
FOR IN THE COURSE OF FOR. OF OF
THIS BUDGET CYCLE BUT I. I WANNA
PARTICULARLY.
A CALL OUT TO THE FOLKS FROM
THE LA OPEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF FROM ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ASSIST US IN
OUR WORK. MOST IMPORTANTLY I
WANT TO THANK MY BUDGET STAFF OF
FARAH BROCK AND SUSAN CHAN WHO.
.
A BOTH OF REALLY STEPPED UP THE
OF THIS YEAR WE'VE HAD A A.
FAIRLY CHAOTIC YEAR INCLUDE SAY.
IT'S NOT EASY TO PUT THIS
BUDGET TO BED BUT.
WILL DO EXACTLY THAT THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND IT'S LARGELY
DUE TO THE.
IMPORTANT WORK THAT TO BUDGET
STAFF DOES TO GET US READY AND
MOVE EVERYTHING FORWARD.
I'M FINALLY AT LIKE SAY THANK
YOU TO ALL THE ADVOCATES AND
FOLKS WHO SHOW UP HERE.
EVERY WEEK FOR MEETINGS AND
REALLY PROVIDE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION AND FEEDBACK TO US
SO THAT WE DO OUR JOB WELL.
MOST OF YOU HAVE ALREADY LEFT
THE ROOM WISELY.
BUT IF YOU'RE LISTENING AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION OUR MEETINGS.
AND WITH THAT.
WE WILL HOLD DATA THE ROLE OPEN
AND.
Y'ALL CAN LEAVE IN ALL SIT HERE
AND WAIT FOR MISTER KALRA.
OH IN MR PATTERSON HAZMAT ON SO
WHAT WE AT TAKE MUCH PATTERSON.
YEAH.
LOOK OKAY AT ALL ACCORDINGLY.
IF YOU WANT.
OKAY OVERHEAD HARPER.
YEAH.
SO.
GROUP.
AND HE'S.
THREE.
YEAH.
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU 11-3 LONGER.
CLEAN.
TWENTY.
AND.
OKAY SHUTTLE.
PATTERSON.
I NEED
.
I AM ELEVEN.
PATTERSON LEVEL.
I'VE EIGHT NINE TWELVE AND
SEVENTEEN PATTERSON THOUGH.
THROUGH YOU A REPEAT TO ECHO.
OKAY THESE ARE ISSUES ONE TWO
FIVE EIGHT NINE TWELVE AND
SEVENTEEN
SPENCER THESE ITEMS ARE FOR
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY. THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL.
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
STATE LANDS COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD. THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD AND
CALTRANS.
MISTER PATTERSON.
WHY DOES YOUR?
ONE.
SO FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY AND
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION PATTERSON.
NO.
AND THEN FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
PATTERSON
OKAY THIS IS UNDER ITEMS TO BE
HEARD. UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION IN THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSALS KALRA.
AND UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TRANSPORTATION
RELATED LEGISLATION KALRA.
I NEGLECTED TO THANK BARBARA
GALLUS WHICH FOR HER. A GREAT
EFFORT THIS YEAR SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT EARLIER THERE'S NOBODY
HERE TO. HAVE TO LISTEN TO BE
SAYING THIS OTHERS ONE PERSON
HERE.
I'M GONNA.
AN ARE SERGEANTS I SHOULD THANK
THE SERGEANTS SEE I JUST DON'T
WANT TO SHUT OFF THE MICROPHONE.
BUT.
WITH THOSE THANK YOUS.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.
FOR THE SEASON